[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Arlo in Texas are
those companies that say they will help
you deal with the IRS legit my husband
and I had several years of unfiled taxes
and fear that we owe the IRS a huge
amount of money can those companies who
claim that they can stop the IRS from
garnishing your wages actually do it
well I'm just wondering why you're
waiting till you get to the point of
garnishing of wages why not just dig a
Little Deeper contact the IRS and find
out what you owe and pay it and by the
way if you're in baby step two if you're
working on paying off your debt this is
going to go right to the top of the list
this is going to be Numero Uno nothing
nothing ahead of it because you don't
want I would change one thing in that
suggestion we're not going to contact
the IRS uh we're going to contact a tax
professional and file our tax ta well
yeah you got to file your taxes tell the
IRS what you owe they're not going to
tell you what you owe you don't want to
ask the IRS anything cuz they don't know
either they're dumber than a rock that
is true they send those statements they
just make up crap so but no you need to
catch up on your tax filings and figure
out where you are and the answer to your
question is no those companies don't
work yeah okay so here's the
thing if you file your
taxes and get caught up the likelihood
of you being criminally charged for
failure to file is very
low when you come forward come out of
the cold so to speak get back on the
grid so to speak and file your taxes
they very seldom criminally charge you
they because failure to pay the IRS is
not a criminal offense failure to file
is a criminal offense M so about
2572 people are something like that
every year last year it's
27572 get put in jail for not filing
their taxes it is a criminal offense
okay so you don't want to screw around
with this you need to right now before
Christmas immediately get online at
Ramsey solutions.com click on our tax
professionals our elps our endorsed
local providers for taxes get your crap
together go over there and get your
taxes filed immediately even if you
don't pay him a dime and you don't have
a dime that's right that's step one get
rid of the probability of a criminal
issue then we'll deal with the
mathematical issue of can they garnish e
wages and are there reductions okay so
let's get into that for just a second
because people are spending more time at
home during the holidays and watching
cable TV and cable news where you see we
have former IRS agents working for us
and we can reduce your tax burden if you
have 10 ,000 or more in IRS debt contact
us and we'll make your life okay in the
fine print it says bull crap okay so uh
because that's what it is so here's the
deal that you can have a tax
professional represent you that is not
on cable TV and they can help you with
the process there's a couple of things
you can do thing one is what Jade said
scratch the money together and pay them
if you're not anywhere near that at
least contact them and you can get on a
payment plan
yeah it's ridiculous penalties and
ridiculous interest M you don't want to
do that if you can get the money
anywhere else including borrowing it
somewhere else and changing your IRS
debt into credit card debt I would have
you do that because it's a better deal
hey say that again because I told
somebody that one time and they had my
head for it no I you I you've got one
kind of debt that's bad debth I would
rather you have a different kind of debt
that is better debt I agree okay let me
just tell you credit card debt is
bankruptable credit card debt has to go
through a legal process to garnish of
your wages IRS debt is not bankruptable
IRS debt has a higher interest rate than
credit card debt has IRS debt can wage
can garnish your wages without going to
court they don't have to get a judge's
permission all other forms of debt have
to do have to so this is the worst kind
of debt to have so if you can make it
into another kind of debt you got a
$20,000 IRS DEET I would lot rather you
owe $220,000 on a credit card than
$20,000 to the KGB amen amen okay and if
if you guys don't like Jade saying that
well you're stupid okay so Jade was
right when she said that that's just
don't be stupid okay it's it makes makes
life painful so the uh the the so now
the next thing is this you do the
payment plan now the other thing they
say is we can reduce your tax
burden
bull yeah they'd have do something Shady
no there there's one way you can do it
legally but it's so thin and narrow is
the door it's called an OIC an offer and
compromise and you can submit to the IRS
your situation and ask that they accept
less than the actual tax debt try to get
them to settle with you like as a
hardship yep when do they approve an
offer in compromise to take your
$100,000 debt and allow you to pay 20
instead okay well you'd have to prove
that you have nothing yeah no income no
potential for income no assets no house
no car no money you are what you have to
prove what they call pper status wow
poor people you got to be homeless
basically penniless and then they will
approve a compromise because they don't
think they're going to get their taxes
anyway but I'm telling you to get an OIC
through and I've gotten a few of them
through I've worked with clients over
the years that were in hardship
situations and had massive tax bills and
we worked with tax attorneys that we
paid good money to not some goober on
cable television okay and you can get an
OIC through but I'm telling you out of a
hundred that I work on or I have worked
on over the years I've gotten three or
four through it just doesn't happen yeah
okay you don't want to be on that status
well you got the things you that you
know it's like well I it's inconvenient
inconvenient they don't care if it's
inconvenient you have a car sell the car
and pay me you have a house sell your
house and pay me mhm they don't care if
you're homeless you don't care your
grandmother's Diamond brooch they don't
care sell it they want to know
everything and not revealing assets to
them in this process is also criminal
fraud yeah so this is just is you're
just playing with tiger here you don't
want to deal with these people what you
want to do is get your taxes filed get
on a payment plan roll up your dadgum
sleeves and clean up your mess and quit
looking for
easy fixes for major stupid stuff
usually major stupid stuff comes with
major problems to fix it yeah there's no
quick and easy you don't get out of debt
quick took you 20 years to make the mess
it a you're not going to get out in 20
minutes and for the self-employed people
that are listening pay your dadgum taxes
just file your quarterly please just do
it and and and if you don't want to do
it yourself invest a little bit of money
and just hire a bookkeeper to stay on
top of this and make sure that that is
going through properly for you I'd
rather pay them a little bit of money
every here than deal with a tax burden
and deal with getting myself in hot
water with the IRS I'm just I'm $199 and
I forgot I had to pay taxes you forgot
you know I mean this is what they I made
100,000 bucks I paid no taxes for two
years that means you made 200,000 bucks
that means you have a tax bill of 50
Grand laying around or more and so you
know that's a lot you do not want to
have this crap sneak up on you it it's
not really sneaking up on you you're
just pretty much uh we just discovered
denial is not just a river in Egypt you
totally stuck your head in the sand
how's that okay so let's make it clear
Dave because we say all the time don't
don't use a professional for this don't
use a guy for this but use a guy for
this so make it clear when do not use
cable TV people to fix anything in your
money we don't use we don't do
consolidation commercial runs between
Snuggies and walk-in bathtubs it's not a
credible operation okay hello not think
about it you know if you're if you're
Financial ad comes between walk-in
bathtubs and Snuggies you got bad
financial advice I'm just telling you
okay that this is what you got think
about what's going on around you
okay create your free every dollar
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life